l'ours polaire c'est l'un des symboles
du manitoba mais avec les changements
climatiques
ces animaux sont menacés et au même
moment on voit apparaître des hybrides
entre des ours polaires et des grizzlies
on les nomme pizzly des ce coin
le public ça ressemble à ça ce sont les
médias qui l'ont baptisé peas ne
prévoyait que les berges
voici l'histoire du pis qui depuis 2006
quelques peas lions ont été chassés 26
avril 2006 il banks
territoires-du-nord-ouest canada 8 avril
2010 il victoria territoires du nord
ouest
mais comment expliquer ce mariage entre
lula et le grizzly le grizzly
c'est un ours capable de s'adapter à
différents climats
la preuve on peut le retrouver en
sibérie en italie au mexique et en
californie
ça c'est un os qui voyagent et avec le
réchauffement climatique des jeunes
grizzlies sont aussi amenés à se
déplacer vers le nord les chercheurs ont
même vu un grizzly acte cherchent ils
au manitoba c'est pourtant la capitale
de l'ours polaire
malgré la présence des deux ours
on n'a pas encore observé de pise liban
nord de la province
pour l'instant c'est peut-être parce que
les ours polaires vivre sur la glace
l'hiver parfois à des centaines de
kilomètres de la terre et les grizzlies
eux
en plus de vivre sur la terre ferme bien
hibernent toutefois la saison de
reproduction des deux ours se
chevauchent vous savez ce que l'on dit
l'amour est aveugle
l'expression auto aussi pour les autres
au printemps les grizzlies qui est leur
tanière il tombe par exemple sur les
traces d'une femelle ours polaires et la
suite des choses
on la connaît avec la fonte des glaces
qu'en est il de l'avenir de l'ours
polaire
les chercheurs pensent qu'il pourrait
survivre pendant trois ou quatre
générations soit jusqu'à la fin des
siècles mais après
les changements climatiques et les
déplacements du grizzly ont permis la
création d'une nouvelle race
selon les chercheurs c'est possible que
l'on voit de plus en plus de public dans
les prochaines années
ces deux espèces qui étaient tenues
séparé justement par des conditions de
glace et deux fois maintenant ce
changement climatique va les ramener
encore ensemble et donc il se peut
effectivement qu'on observe de plus en
plus de cadres d'hybridation entre ces
deux espèces là le nord du manitoba à sa
capitale de l'ours polaire qui sait si
un jour on va y retrouver une capitale
de pise lee
[Musique]